?
>> CASEY, STAND BY.
WE'LL CHECK BACK WITH YOU LATER.
>> John: GILLIAN, LET'S BRING IN
TONY GONZALEZ, REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN.
HE REPRESENTS THE LARGERS
BOARDER DISTRICT IN TEXAS
STRETCHING 800 MILES.
GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
A LOT OF CRITICISM FOR THE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR GOING TO EL PASO
DESPITE THE McCOWAN, HIDALGO
AREA.
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S OFFICE SAID
OF EL PASO, IT REPRESENTS LARGER
BORDER DYNAMICS AND IT'S A
CRITICAL PART OF UNDERSTANDING
THE HUMAN EXPERIENCE OF
MIGRATION.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE NUMBERS.
THE RIO GRANT VALLEY, THE YEAR
TO DATE, 219,788 BORDER
ENCOUNTERS VERSUS EL PASO.
85,273.
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
WHAT THE VICE PRESIDENT WOULD
SEE IN RIO GRANT AS OPPOSED TO
EL PASO?
>> I REPRESENT OVER 40% OF THE
BORDER.
IT'S VERY DIVERSE.
KAMALA'S FIRST VISIT TO THE
BORDER AS VICE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN A HUGE FLOP.
SHE'S JUST PARACHUTED IN, ONLY
LISTENED TO FOLKS FOR A FEW
HOURS.
THAT IS NOT HOW YOU LISTEN TO
FOLKS AND NOT HOW YOU RESPOND TO
IT.
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN EL PASO IS
DIFFERENT THAN THE DEL RIO
SECTOR OR BIG BEND SECTOR.
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
THEY'RE SAYING THEY'RE MAKING
PROGRESS.
IN CULBERSON COUNTY CLOSE TO EL
PASO, THERE WAS A 35-YEAR-OLD
MAN TRAVELING WITH HIS
15-YEAR-OLD SON FROM ECUADOR.
THEY MADE THE TREK.
GUESS WHAT?
HIS 15-YEAR-OLD SON DIES BECAUSE
THEY GOT SEPARATED FROM A GROUP.
HE DIED A HORRIBLE DEATH.
NOT HAVING ANY WATER.
THAT IS THE REALITY OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING ON THE GROUND.
MIGRANTS ARE DYING.
>> John: YEAH, NO QUESTION ABOUT
THAT.
THE HEAT CONTINUES TO BUILD AS
WELL, IT GETSMORE AND MORE
DANGEROUS.
CHAD WOLF SAYS HE DOESN'T EXPECT
TO BE THE TYPICAL DECLINE IN
MIGRATION IN THE HOT SUMMER
MONTHS.
I WANT TO POINT OUT BECAUSE WE
WANT TO BE FAIR AND BALANCED AT
FOX NEWS.
KAMALA HARRIS IS GETTING A LOT
OF CRITICISM FOR GOING TO EL
PASO.
IN MARCH, A CONGRESSIONAL
DELEGATION LED BY THE HOUSE
MINORITY LEADER, KEVIN McCARTHY
WENT TO EL PASO.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID DURING THAT
VISIT.
>> I CAME DOWN HERE BECAUSE I
HEARD OF THE CRISIS.
IT'S MORE THAN A CRISIS.
THIS IS A HUMAN HEART BREAK.
THE SAD PART ABOUT THIS IS IT
DIDN'T HAVE TO HAPPEN.
THIS CRISIS IS CREATED BY THE
PRESIDENTIAL POLICIES OF THIS
NEW ADMINISTRATION.
>> John: HE WAS VERY CRITICAL.
NOBODY CRITICIZED HIM GOING TO
EL PASO SAYING YOU MISSED THE
STORY IN RIO GRANDE VALLEY
SECTOR.
SO WHY IS THE VICE PRESIDENT
GETTING CRITICISM FOR DOING THE
SAME THING?
>> I WAS ON THAT VISIT IN MARCH.
WHAT WE SAW THEN IS RECORD
NUMBERS.
THE PROCESSING CENTER WHERE HE
VISITED TODAY, IT WAS BEYOND AT
CAPACITY.
NOW, I'VE VISITED THE SAME
PROCESSING CENTER SINCE THEN.
THE NUMBERS HAVE GONE DOWN IN
THE EL PASO SECTOR.
THERE'S OTHER SECTORS THAT
HAVE -- THE NUMBERS HAVE ONLY
INCREASED.
DEL RIO AND THE RIO GRANDE
VALLEY IN PARTICULAR.
SO WHAT I GET AT, THIS BORDER
PATROL IS ALWAYS SHIFTING AND
ALWAYS MOVING.
YOU CAN'T LAND SOMEWHERE AND
BECOME AN EXPERT.
YOU HAVE TO DEDICATE THE TIME
AND EFFORT FROM ALL OF US, FROM
EL PASO TO DEL RIO, TO RIO
GRANDE VALLEY, LAREDO.
I HOPE THIS IS THE FIRST OF MANY
VISITS THAT SHE MAKES TO TACKLE
THIS PROBLEM.
>> John: SOMETHING REALLY POPPED
OUT AT ME WHEN THE VICE
PRESIDENT'S DELEGATION LANDED
THERE IN EL PASO.
CONGRESS WOMAN VERONICA ESCOBAR
SAID WELCOME TO THE NEW ELLIS
ISLAND.
MAKING COMPARISONS BETWEEN
EL PASO AND THE MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE THAT CAME THROUGH ELLIS
ISLAND IN A WAVE OF IMMIGRATION
TO THE UNITED STATES IN THE
EARLY 20th CENTURY.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF THAT
COMMENT?
>> A BIG DIFFERENCE.
LOOK, WE'RE A NATION OF
IMMIGRANTS AND ALSO A NATION OF
LAWS.
OUR LAWS MUST BE FOLLOWED.
WHAT I MAKE OUT OF IT IS WE NEED
TO REFORM OUR LEGAL IMMIGRATION
PROCESS.
AT THE SAME TIME, WE HAVE TO
UPHOLD OUR LAWS.
PEOPLE DON'T FEEL SAFE
ENCOURAGING FOLKS TO MAKE THIS
TREK ILLEGALLY IS WRONG.
WE NEED TO REFORM OUR LEGAL
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM, WELCOME
THOSE THAT WANT TO COME LIVE THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
DO IT THROUGH A LEGAL FASHION.
WHEN WE START ENCOURAGING FOLKS
TO COME OVER ILLEGALLY, WHICH IS
EXACTLY WHAT THIS ADMINISTRATION
HAS DONE, THAT IS THE WRONG
APPROACH.
THAT UNRAVELS AMERICA.
WE STAND FOR LAW AND ORDER.
>> John: CONGRESSMAN GONZALEZ,
THANKS.
WE'RE EXPECTING TO HEAR FROM T